die jeden Patrioten jeden das jeden der
Deutschland liebt und will dass es
diesem Land gut geht muss das besorgen
denn wir wissen um was für eine Partei
es sich handelt man kann sie jetzt
gerade nachlesen bitte welche
Geheimpläne sie machen übrigens in der
Landwirtschaft muss man wissen im
Grundsatzprogramm steht drin dass sie
nicht nur kfzsteuer Agrardiesel alle
Subvention für die Landwirtschaft
abschafft und trotzdem gibt's ja Leute
im ländlichen Raum die in der AFD ein
Hoffnungsträger sehen auch da bin ich
wieder Sozialpädagoge ich sehe da die
Verantwortung auch bei uns die Ampel hat
jetzt durch durch den Streit leider
nicht geholfen aber auch die Union hilft
nicht in dem sin eine Sprache benutzt
die haben sie ja gerade benutzt die am
Ende doch gar nicht bei der Union einzah
und die zahlt ein bei den radikalen
Rändern das ist ja nicht nur die AFD das
ist Frau Wagenknecht das ist Herr Maßen
wie die alle heißen die dieses Land von
ihnen kaputt machen wollen und wir sind
jetzt einfach aufgefordert als
Demokraten das Land in der Mitte
zusammenzuhalten sonst drohen dieses
Jahr Ergebnisse wo Fanatiker
radikale in die Exekutive kommen